welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down Rebel Moon part one it's a
new age for the
universe titled the child of fire
there's a hell of a lot to talk about
with there not only being a sequel
coming but also an extended version Yep
they're doing another SN car but I kind
of feel like this is a marketing play
purely by the studio has it backfire
well the reviews aren't looking good and
honestly it is kind of difficult to
review myself knowing that a longer and
potentially better version that sorts
out the issues in this is dropping soon
makes it weird to talk about from a
critical point of view Snider said his
version is a and I quote completely
different movie and that he wanted the r
cut to be his it's kind of weird knowing
this isn't what Zach intended and
there's already been a bit of damage
control it's been said it's all tied up
in what Netflix want to release first
but yeah they have a streaming service
and I do doing a longer one in a few
months so personally I see them looking
at the SN cut movement and how much the
demand dominated social media to me they
may be hoping it makes everyone double
dip with rumors of the other cut keeping
interest in the film I mean director's
Cuts in general they've been a big
marketing thing for decades with it
making people buy alternate versions of
films so they can see the true Vision if
you've got the alien box set then you
might remember R Scott actually opens it
up by introducing his new card but
basically saying he still thinks the
atrical one is the best version the
director's Cuts actually shorter and
contains less shots and Scott said it
was done purely to sell the box set so
cynical spoilers I'll forever remain but
we will get into it as we discuss the
movie anyway that's my longest intro
ever and heavy spoilers ahead from this
point out please smash the Thumbs Up
Button if you enjoy it and don't forget
to subscribe for videos like this every
day without the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into Rebel
moon when I found you in the wage of
that
ship I considered leaving you I was
afraid you could bring trouble to
[Music]
us what do you think they
want everything now as with all sci-fi
epics there's a lot of Law and things to
unpack inspired by M of Juni and Star
Wars sniders crafted a galactic spanning
tail a long time ago in a galaxy far far
away we learn of the mother World which
had a Royal bloodline that was so
lustful for power it consumed all the
planet's resources sending its Army into
space they attempted to conquer all
however this need for power caused the
subjects to rise up both the king and
queen were killed along with their
daughter but we'll talk about how that
might not be the case later on now in
our world when it comes to rebellion and
a coronation people just stand outside
holding banners and stuff but here it's
worse than when a heavy spoilers video
gets a limited ad symbol and he has to
upload the same crap video twice not
really as good as Anthony Hopkins doing
it is it but either way there were
Whispers of revolution on the outer
worlds and a senator named Valaria sees
power in the vacuum now a region he set
out to renew the Empire's strength
through his loyalist follower Admiral
adus Noble his One mission is to crush
the Rebels rebels spelled m o n he said
it he said it that but if you if you
read the stand I hope you appreciate it
anyway this is where we meet Kora a farm
girl on the planet V Val means un
cultivated land but I feel like the word
may be a nod to The Watchmen in that
oas's real name was Adrien VI and SNY of
course directed the film adaptation it's
a bit of a reach but we learned
throughout the film that Kora was once
part of the Imperium but that she crash
landed on the planet and has been lying
low ever since with Nobles and Noble
Quest out and the Stars raging on we see
as this event she takes him to V Noble
is currently hunting a group known as
Clan blood Axe and he demands supplies
in order to continue the mission the
cheeky cheeky people of Val live on a
fertile and Rich Planet but they're like
ah mate it's prop a crap this drier than
my n Stu luus you you know what I'm
saying what beating The Village's leader
father cindry to death Noble tells
Gunner that he has 10 weeks to have
supplies Ready Gunner started believing
that they could be partners and he
dropped cindry in it by bragging about
how much they had Gunner sword is an
opportunity but all they care about is
Conquest in power Kora just wants to
keep her cover and lie low but Noble
leaves some soldiers behind to make sure
there's no funny business amongst this
is a Droid who comes to be known as
Jimmy and he comes from a long line of
robotic Knights ever since their King
was killed they refuse to fight but when
it comes to Sam he starts to intervene
this might be a clue at who Sam is but
he tells us of the king's and queen's
daughter who was known as a redeemer
that was seen as a person who could save
the mother World known as Issa the ISA a
resemblance to villager Sam which leads
into Jimmy spouting off about her again
can't do it as well as Hopkins but we
discover that Cora was once her
bodyguard after her world was taken by
the Imperium she was raised by bisari
and turned into a warrior she never knew
why he spared her life but she did go to
pull the trigger on him so perhaps he
saw strength I think we will learn more
about him in part two and I have a few
time few time you about what that is
Aura says that he saw something in her
eyes and my guess is that they had a
similar childhood we know the Imperium
conquered many worlds and I feel like he
would have been in a similar position
you also learn that the soldiers were
encouraged to love so that they had an
attachment during the fury of war bisari
is without one when we see him and I
think that like Kora he probably lost
his maybe in her he saw something else
and a child that he could raise as the
person he was in love with didn't
survive long enough to have one with him
does that make sense is that a theory
time I don't know but I kind of feel
like that's where we're going however
there's also the fact that she's the
scar Giver which could TI with Issa Issa
was seen as the future for the world and
a way they'd lost student while their
War Isa was able to give life and this
power was s to be something that could
regenerate the mother World Kora being a
young girl as well could have been an
opposite to her and a way to bring death
across the entire galaxy we know that
part two has the subtitle scar Giver so
it's likely going to be what the entire
film focuses on we learn she is the most
Wanted fugitive in the entire galaxy and
potentially she's the Assassin that
killed the Royals this talk about how
her death came from giving charity to an
off- welder which in many ways fits in
with that perhaps her father got his
surrogate daughter to carry it out and
that was the reason that he became
Regent again theories but she says she
felt guilt over the assassination and
that's the reason that she fled in the
end she sees some soldiers assaulting
Sam and smashes them like they the like
button jimmmy comes in and stands up to
his Masters leaving just a soldier ARIS
who stood up to them too at this point
they head out to the Providence in order
to do a Seven Samurai making their own
band of Warriors they start to assemble
a cast of characters that can help out
in the fight against Noble now I feel
like this is where you can really see a
lot of the movie was cut down as we have
the pacing kind of all over the place
some characters come in and are taking
out as fast as they arrive and you
really wonder if they were even needed
at all obviously I'm guessing these
would get more room in the extended car
and it would feel a bit less break neck
as always SN uses slowmo action scenes
and this does give them a sense of his
own unique style I don't think he could
have cut them down and had the movie
still look as good however I think this
might add into what people are
criticizing the film for again I don't
think you could cut them but when you
have to cut the other stuff it then
leads to some plot issues I kind of
compare it to Batman v Superman in which
I thought the Extended Cut sorted all
the issues out I really enjoy that
version but the theatrical cut got rid
of a lot of the cohesive moments that
helped to fill in some of the the
questions that you might have that was
obviously all Studio mandated and I feel
like this is history repeating itself
there's a lot of characters but Snider's
not being given the run time to do them
justice so was either cut them out
completely or cut down the character
development that's for the side ones but
I genuinely think cor gets a lot and
there was enough here to keep me
invested speaking of history repeating
itself they then got to what's basically
Rebel Moon's most iy Cantina which is
where they're seeking info about a
character named Titus played by Deon h
Zoo he's a former Imperium General who
just like K is rebelling against the
rulers now the canena his kite played by
Charlie hunam who who's basically your
Han Solo Rebel Moon also a bit of trivia
did you know that Han Solo is the Han
Solo of Han Solo a solo story anyway
there's also T who can bond with animals
and my favorite character which is
Nemesis though her weapons are getting
compared to lightsabers I think they do
enough with them to distance her and
she's probably The Stand Out character
design wise leaning heavily with the
samurai influences the way she shot just
leaps off the screen think it has to be
said that as usual that's one of s's
greatest strengths and watching her
slice of Peter Parker's wet dream woman
is a good Standalone scene the score is
also in a really similar vein to Batman
v Superman so hey if you like that
you're going to like this too at point I
even thought it might be that but it's
such an amazing soundtrack I didn't mind
it at all in the end a meeting is
brought together with the clan blood axe
which is headed up by Daran and debah
Daran and his half of the clan they
agree to help whereas debah sees it as
just being a loss anyway Kai ends up
betraying the rebels after he says that
he has to drop off some cargo it's a
trap we discover that Kai's home was
ravaged by the Imperium and he's seen
firsthand how deadly they are captured
Noble riffs off the famous band of
rebels and realizes that Kora is the
scar Giver this is when gunna's ordered
to execute Kora but instead he frees her
like actually frees her not that I will
free you and then they kill them which
leads to a massive battle they're Rebels
they've gone Rog call Tom Cruz the
bloody gone Rogue now the battle isn't
without its losses either as Darion gets
killed during it thus I think his
sisters going to step up to the mark and
avenge your brother come part two Coral
also goes to to with Noble and he seems
to fall to his death however however
however we like to see Noble's bodies
recovered and he's surrounded by the red
priests that we've seen throughout the
film I don't know if this is an a to
Dungeons and Dragons but they're doing
something that looks like it could be
necromancy either way it leads to him
newly being in conference with balis
Arius who demands Cory's return to him
he states that he wants to publicly
execute her and if Noble fails that
he'll be the one who gets it hadak kiss
and wakes up with his orders clear and
though he's been given another chance at
life we don't know how long that will be
and a man's on borrow time too makes me
wonder if Isa is still alive and this is
how the machine man manages to bring him
back guy is definitely dead but this
like her powers it has Resurrection now
as for cor and Co they head to Val which
is where we catch Jimmy now rocking
antlers the war is coming and they need
to get ready as the sequels are going to
be dropping in April they say it would
have been a beautiful place to die it
would have made but we're not bloody G
to now there's a teaser on Netflix that
pops off immediately after and though I
can't get a copy of it I can bloody
describe it as the villagers training
and getting ready for a fight and we
also see the generals passed at the
Battle playing out Darion shows have
been a two but I feel like this moment
with a prior one are purely flashbacks
they also give the idea that Sam's
skilled as well and again I I do start
to suspect if she's actually Issa Jimmy
did say that she shared a resemblance
and maybe cor fled with her and faked to
death she was her bodyguard and she's of
course carrying the bloodline and I
wonder if she's hiding and will come
back and lead in the future Jimmy also
he's really shaking himself out of his
apathy so perhaps seeing her you know he
just drew the connections that would
make sense about why he turned against
his Masters as he was trying to protect
Sam who could potentially be Issa Issa
big Theory time um but yeah that's how I
feel and leave your comments below as
I'd love to hear them now if you enjoy
the content we make and want to support
us and please consider joining the
spoiler side Squad by clicking the join
button for just 99 p and 99 cents a
month you'll get early access to our
podcast every week and also all a
classic movie break Downs that we drop
on the channel we've got die hard on
there right now so yeah just click CL
and you'll get to see it early now if
you love movies as much as we do as well
and want to save some money then we're
also giving 10% off at our partners
Arrow video they do a ton of cult
classics on 4K and by using the Cod
heavy spoilers you get 10% off the
savings are amazing anyway as for my
thoughts on the movie it's kind of
difficult to get into them because as I
said I know a longer Cuts coming
director's Cuts again are really weird
because it it's like the studio
admitting that they meddled in the
entire thing however there's lots of
reasons why they're Creed in general but
more times than not they're done to
achieve the artistic vision of the
director with them releasing years and
sometimes even decades down the line
Blade Runner is a great example and
really Scott was forced to have
narration put into the film because the
studio worried that audiences would be
lost they also forced Scott to use
b-roll from The Shining at the end and
this was in order to give the movie a
happy ending even when the director's
cut of this was loed about it wasn't
even really a director's cut as someone
else edited it and Scott just gave notes
so years later they did the Final Cut
Which Scott got to over see however
director's Cuts can be dangerous and
that's because people change for example
George Lucas has changed his minor where
handshot first like 95 times now and
Spielberg also got addicted to tinkering
with his movies as he spent a ton of
money on ET this is in order to alter
the guns and change them to
walkie-talkies but he ended up turning
them back because he he changed his mind
again tweaks like this can become
dangerous and to me we're kind of in a
death of author situation where once
it's an audience's hands it sort of
belongs to them in the end a lot of
changes can often end up angering fans
and there's tons of videos running about
the Star Wars special editions however
you also have fans getting angry at the
studio for holding back the director and
forcing them to put something out in the
first place that they didn't want to
release now why I'm saying all of this
is so I can explain why I just don't get
why Netflix have done what they've done
little mistakes left in stuff you know I
think it adds to the charm of a movie
and not every single thing needs to be
tweaked until it's perfect we could even
get to a point where fan movements
constantly demand a theas of films to a
point that it becomes a bigger talking
point than what else's studio is trying
to release I think that's something
we've seen happen with Snider before and
though I get called a Snider shill a lot
I think that's because I enjoy pretty
much all those movies now Netflix own
their streaming servers and they can put
anything on it as long as they want
they're not really held back by movie
theaters who only have a certain amount
of time to show movies a day and a
certain amount of screens thus I can't
help but feel like this is just a
marketing tactic by them to try and
capture some of the fandom and attention
Snider to me is up there with being
someone who I associate with director's
C and that isn't just because of what
happened with Justice League Watchmen
Watchmen right I bought the DVD then
bought the director's cut then bought
the Blu-ray and then the director cup
Blu-ray then I bought the ultimate
edition Blu-ray and then I bought the 4K
and then the 4K Ultimate Edition and
then the 4K color corrected Ultimate
Edition clearly Chums like me will keep
buying as long as we promised better
versions of the films be like but
there's not really many I can think of
where I went back to the theatrical once
the director's Cuts released I think
that's how I feel about Rebel Moon as
well and a lot of the characters are
introduced in the movie before we get a
chance to know them some plot threads
have points can feel like they get way
too much attention while other threads
are cut down to the point they don't
feel developed at all now do I think
these issues will be fixed in the
extended version yes I I actually do
which is why it's so annoying because I
genuinely feel like the pieces are there
there's really good stuff scattered
throughout but in the back of my mind
when I was watching this and and we had
something cut down I thought oh well
that's probably going to be in the
director's cut now visually Snider's on
his a game as usual and it's crazy how
much better this looks than most movies
out there everything about a pops and
most of the film you could pause
screenshot it and use that as a postcard
the production design is excellent too
and these characters feel like they've
been ripped right out of a greaty comic
book in the end it's annoying because I
can see the potential but judging off
this cut I feel the film falls short the
movie's also getting lambasted on ronto
modos which is frustrating because we
know what else is being with hell to
make fans double dip to me though what I
view is a marketing moves backfired a
bit because this is supposed to be
launching a new universe I genuinely
think there'll be a chunk of the
audience that don't go back to this at
all even with the director's C
eventually being released when you got
sequels banging on it as well it's like
they've purposely started off on the
wrong foot which is weird and if you
haven't seen the film yet and for
whatever reason I'm just watching this
video then my advice is to wait just
wait and watch the R-rated version when
that comes out don't let Netflix know
they can do this sort of thing with part
two and please Netflix just release the
film that you should have done the first
time let us judge that instead of having
to wait it out and watch lesser ones
because I think all the bad PR around
this has soured a of the discourse if
people switch off on this new universe
and Netflix kind of have themselves to
blame and I suspect many people might
not want to go back so yeah this is a
weird one to review and though I think
there are parts to like it's clearly
been a hatchet job now there's also
potential that aror c will have issues
too and what it could lead to is people
dunking on it for there being two bad
versions of what should be the same
movie so yeah I think that's weird but
just going off this Vision I think the
fults held it back and what we get a
compromised film now there has been
enough here to keep me invested and I
will be back to talk about that Extended
Cut if you want to see that then please
subscribe and make sure you leave your
thoughts on the film and the situation
behind it please drop a like on the
video also I know it's weird when you're
reviewing a film and you're sort of
talking about the history of director's
Cuts in general but in the case of this
one I just feel like I had to bring it
up now obviously there's going to be a
lot to talk about but if you've enjoyed
this and please hit the like button you
want something else to watch we've got a
video on screen right now so definitely
head over there right after this this by
the way huge thank you for sing through
the video I've been Paul you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace